j'ai posé une question et vous allez me
répondre
pas trop compliqué pour vous un bon
alors vous me dites que vous sortez du
film conversion la barre je vous dit que
c'est pas mal et aux confessions la
barge ou à queue surtout personne ne l'a
vu le temps que les gens sortent nous on
aura pas de lumière il va faire nuit de
vous dit que c'est pas mal et tout le
monde dit personne comme ça en fait le
sujet qu'est ce qu'on attend leno
attention on tourne mademoiselle vous
sentez de quel film confession d'un
barjots avec avec regardez moi regarder
la caméra je pense à rien
comédien mère chez oh c'est merveilleux
merveilleux alors ça vous a plu ou pas
c'est par ce qui se passe au début
rappelons le il tombe
quelle est la salle cuzacq plus marqué
alors quand il fait du chemin
quand tu couches
ils l'ont
l'embrasement mois quand ils se battent
oui sept heures
[Rires]
toutefois on veut pas laisser dire ça
peut-il ça dérape on leur pète alors là
c'est sûr le film c'est un câble casting
on n'a pas du tout mais je vais le voir
là bas justement ce matin pour le fait
devant la piche tu l'as pas vu encore on
va faire comme si tu l'avais vu tu nous
lis juste deux mots parce que nous
apprennent à coup de lumière veut pas de
tourner ok c'est bien parce que c'est
des sommes bien d'accord
c'est comme si tu sortais de deux de la
ligne sites au club dominique besnehard
bonjour vous sortez de quel film
confession d'un par jour
alors à vos impressions qui va
maintenant un film très original très
avec un humour très décapants et les
aides sont vraiment étonnants notamment
anne brochet qui est complètement contre
emploi est vraiment intéressant et c'est
le film auquel vous vous attendiez en
rentrant c'est à dire que j'avais lu le
scénario
c'est un peu mal mal placé donc quand on
lit un scénario où on a toujours une
idée sur le fil mais je doute que la
forme est vraiment et la fin
la chance aussi des annales des animaux
comme dans son précédent film est la
scène qui vous a le plus marqué la scène
où à l'heure où j'aime beaucoup la scène
nous ou comment il s'appelle la caméra
hippolyte arrive avec sa soeur qu'il
provoque et tout ça sachets de thé une
scène vraiment bien joué j'ai comme il
ya 74 samedi - lors d un jeune ambra
surprise ce sont tous des allures de
regarder les sont tous des amis je les
embrasse moi c'est à dire moi ces
objectifs ça va changer d'objectif
car le
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus